hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to super Wolfenstein HD the
remake actually this is the physics
remake I forget who told me to play this
game it was another youtuber I was just
with might have been Jack not exactly
sure but he said it was hilarious and it
came out of the recent gamejolt Beauty
by game jam so I'm gonna play it and see
what happening because it's remake of
Wolfenstein which is a classic game by
ed software from way back when that I
have not played in years so I'm not
gonna have any point of comparison to do
this with hello thank you alright so I
get it I need to throw knives actually
don't remember the game all that much I
beat it
I know Hitler into the wall
can I break down everything this is
awesome
it's like what was that game from a long
time ago thank you who's a game that was
this completely destructible environment
it was like Red Faction Red Faction that
was it oh okay I thought I lost him I
don't think there's any point to carving
through the walls just yet I know to
finish you guys off he gave me one last
look before he disappeared into you piss
oh my god I love the physics we make the
physics is the best oh that's incredible
and is there any like secret behind
these walls that I would give it oh well
I effectively lost my knives so that's
probably uh oh hello okay I remember
that there was no up-and-down in the
original Wolfenstein doom was one of the
first games to introduce elevation
changes that's why I say this game was
created a because you know
wait did I say that it was one of the
first 3d games but it wasn't like you
were able to move around in like a
first-person dungeon crawler it was the
first first-person game it was kind of
three it was definitely three I don't
wanna die let me just let me just throw
the oh god get in the Wolcott in the
walk-in the walk get all the way in the
wall let me take care of you first you
got a machine gun
Oh once with the pistol I like my knives
a little better conscious escape into
the wall goodbye oh that was a zombie
who knew what Hill okay who knew what
Hitler was doing with his soldiers way
back when oh god I love it Blackwall
okay
so cool oddly booted get you oh I feel
bad I don't want to shoot the puppy I
don't shoot the puppy
oh god his butts a jiggling alright get
in the water get into wall into the wall
I need to cover up my shame of what I've
done
skin in the wall that's wrong I guess
I'll just move along now no one saw
anything suspicious okay
No
oh do I have to start over at the
beginning wait I think this is the
second level okay would you be good
right yeah yeah this time not be so
wasting bullet I'm spending too much
time marveling at how hilarious this is
and I'm not actually playing the game
which is what I should do Oh
believer get in the wall uh-huh are you
gonna get back up you Sambi weirdo
he is getting back up how can you do
that you're very dead okay bye these
guys just all right
something not right about him bonk sorry
puppy sorry booty sorry there he's alive
he's just eating there don't mind him is
like the best game I've ever seen in my
life this game turn out to be the most
awesome game I've ever played come back
Monday oh my goodness
what the world / Willy booties are not
allowed
man it's like battlefield I can break
through out of school to shoot people
think around the battlefield whatever
whatever the slogan was arf arf arf arf
arf arf all right all right we're gonna
play your way I'm almost dead
stims hard this game is hard when you
don't take it seriously he was just
laughing at everything that was
happening
hang on here it's got to be a secret did
I go through there sorry Poochie I think
I did yeah I did I need health real bad
I keep I keep letting myself get shot
way too much my leaving my leaving
strudel oh no you're coming with me
young man okay never mind I'm going into
the next level I don't know how many
levels
I don't oh well this seems like the
exact same level I was at this is the
exact same level did I just loop around
I did I thought it was wait maybe wait
that didn't seem quite the same thank
you Cincinnati has a great many
Oktoberfest meaning that it has one I'm
very used to that painting mine here
knives not that I need not those are big
oh no those are double No hey don't get
back up I write in your knee will you
see that you loser with your Nazi pistol
okay bye
wait a minute some [ __ ]
a lot of people are shooting at me but I
don't know if I should be worried about
it was doing good god damn you name is
actually got hard like seriously
very hard oh this is here just in case I
die that way I can get it back again
okay that makes sense a submachine gun I
need some extra firepower cuz apparently
I'm not able to kill these guys with my
normal stuff they just don't die right
away
look you're leaving I lock all your
leavings gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme
back you disappeared through the wall
these guys not die I don't think they
die
okay I had the body got the body oh
you're white well I guess that's to be
but I'm saying they're Nazis so that
makes sense break break did I get you I
didn't get you just get beat God I have
two knives for you thank you and then
bullets and this time I'm not gonna
waste them says markiplier the guy who
wastes sings one shot one push into a
wall one kill
Oh God how'd you get back no one's out
fear so is this bull
okay okay you just you doodle I shot him
in his cross and all I could think about
is is rudl no it was nothing
BYE MOM I really don't know whether the
end of this game is but it's really fun
this game is free you weren't supposed
to be here
you cartwheeling never-ending dying
doggies boom stay down Poochie
I don't like it makes me shoot doggies
but at least these don't actually die
they just kind of all around and keep
like okay I'm done fighting it's all
right thanks though I appreciate it Oh
with my future you stay away hey buddy
hey buddy look him right in the crotch
in the eye the exact weak points on the
male anatomy yes yes
I need more weights way too much of this
booty hey booty smile even he might be
dead okay I'm gonna move on now all
right
okay
you take away by doggy
don't you do it's not pizza no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no right into by still live Hogan I
gotcha octal even up my nose in Steinem
but my nose in strudel give me the
special items back here because I know
there was something give me give me give
me give me this game is ludicrously fun
you guys got a plate it's awesome in
every way oh man hey guys is
breakdancing dumb on him back barf at
birth can save two shots for the doggies
they're staying down okay good whoa whoa
whoa I need this I need this
I just gotta knock that guy down and
he's not much of a threat
whoa whoa e the stray bullets might be
octal even stewed or believe in Steinem
no I got a better gun
there we go got him octal even you go
into the wall in Steinem Oh God alright
then it's pretty faithful recreations of
the monsters here - the physics of
course I don't know I kind of want to
play this game to the end oh I did play
the game to the most fun I bet there's
secrets that I didn't fight because
Wolfenstein and doom were notorious for
dozens and dozens of Secrets so go check
it out this game should be made into a
full game its software hires whoever
made this and make a game out of it
because it was absolutely awesome so
thank you all so much for watching look
in the description for the link to the
game and other awesome games that I
played in the past click the annotation
for more videos from me and as always I
will see you